[Music]
well the streak continues as noted by
cardinals spokesperson mark dalton
yesterday barring something completely
unexpected tonight cuba gooding jr will
be the only person to ever win an
academy award for portraying an arizona
cardinals wide receiver however peter
king last night regina king won an oscar
for a completely different role but she
was the wife of cuba gooding jr's
character in jerry maguire so there is
some connection there back to cuba
gooding jr and his oscar for
uh his role in jerry maguire so we have
that all right we're gonna we're gonna
have a draft he's sort of he's certainly
he's sort of the six degrees of
separation the uh the matt damon guy
because every year at the oscars time
you know the cardinals tweet out
something about cuba gooding jr they
just they love that part of their
history
well you know what when you don't have a
super bowl trophy i guess some indirect
connection to an oscar is the next best
thing i mean
it's sad but it's true all right uh sad
but true we're gonna move on with our
draft for today and this is in honor of
the oscars and this is the player the
player about whom the best biopic could
be made we saw bohemian rhapsody with
the freddie mercury deal and that kind
of inspired it remy malek won the oscar
for best actor portraying freddie
mercury so what player could we have
current or all time the best biopic made
based on that person's life peter king
is always you get to call the coin toss
i continue to insist it's rigged we'll
see based upon how it turns out today
i'm gonna pick tails mike
tails never fails and tails is usually
that's how it's rigged to land and of
course there it is peter gets the first
choice and i know for me there's one
that stands out above all others but
we'll see if peter and i agree peter i
don't know who you're gonna who your
number one is but mine is jim brown
and the reason that i would pick jim
brown you know the uh the fantastic
running back in my opinion the greatest
running back in nfl history is that jim
brown retired in the early 60s at the
peak of his power after winning an nfl
rushing title and he retired from the
set of the dirty dozen
which was being filmed in london at the
time and he was one of the stars
in a movie with lee marvin called the
dirty dozen and he retired because he
thought that football was sort of
limiting
uh
excuse me limiting his ability to be a
complete person
and i think he's had a fascinating life
since then
somewhat sordid life at times
but he's also been a major leader uh you
know in a lot of civil rights area civil
rights areas with players
um so i'll take jim brown mike
yeah you know what he was on my list but
he wasn't my top choice my top choice
without question without question given
everything that this guy experienced and
it would be high comedy more than
anything else growing up in mississippi
and finding his way to to southern miss
where he ended up being an unlikely star
he had the car crash when he was young
just this fun-loving guy and god the the
years from college and into his early
time in the nfl
it would be you may have to do a trilogy
on the life of brett favre but without
question for me brett favre and it would
be i i read the the jeff perlman
biography of brett favre and it was
fascinating and you think of a life this
guy led before football in football
with the falcons with the packers with
the jets with the vikings it would be
drama after drama after comedy after
comedy brett favre to me without
question the best biopic you could have
for someone who played in the nfl
mike i mean you're right it would be
hard to do that in one
half hour show or one hour show or one
three hour show i think that would be a
series that would be a netflix series
so i like that pick for you my second
one is a little bit too easy and i
apologize in advance but colin
kaepernick
um for for for this reason
you know he basically has become a
sphinx
since he's left the game unless he's
being honored by
some uh lofty committee or at harvard or
overseas or somewhere
we just don't know this guy you know
what's going through this guy's head
what he's thinking
he is
america's lightning rod
and that's why no matter what you think
of them
you'd watch the biopic on colin
kaepernick
you know that's a great call and i had
not thought of that one peter and you
know he's been in the news lately let me
ask you this have you heard anything to
suggest that there is a team out there
ready to pull the trigger and sign him
no and in fact mike
last weekend i was in san francisco
visiting
uh my my family in san francisco and
uh my daughter and and and the uh and
her wife and their grandchildren
and i made two phone calls
to teams that i felt might
might
have an interest okay
and i got no sense from either one
that there was going to be any
rekindling
of any interest that they might have
once had so
i heard what his attorney said that hey
there are teams out there that that are
interested in him or however he phrased
it
i i don't see it mike i don't think he's
going to play football again
yeah i agree with you but whether he
plays or not a life already that would
be and and probably of all the ones
we've discussed so far probably the most
likely to end up being a biopic and it
would be very compelling what he
sacrificed why he did it how he grew up
everything that goes into it that's what
i love about a good biopic i and that
was what disappointed me not to become
uh siskel and ebert here peter but
bohemian rhapsody really disappointed me
because i wanted to know more about what
made freddie mercury who he was and it
just kind of jumps right in as he's on
the verge of joining queen i want to
know more about the i i like to get into
that
how a guy ended up being how he
discovered his talent the first time he
realized he was really good and where it
went from there so uh anyway that's uh
that's uh my my quick uh five cent
review of bohemian rhapsody joe namath i
don't know that bohemian rhapsody would
be the best title for joe namath
joe namath is a joan because here's the
thing i thought about more modern
players but joe namath played at a time
where
we didn't have everyone's life as an
open book
and there wasn't the internet and we
weren't in the nooks and crannies of
private lives and i've heard enough
about joe namath just from you know
things i've seen over the years about
twists and turns in his career i'd love
to see that full joe namath story from
growing up to being in alabama to
becoming broadway joe to the things that
almost almost
completely derailed his career when he
was tied in with you know a guy that
owned a bar that was that was mobbed up
all those things where he retired for a
short period of time and then came back
and and everything post football joe
namath would be another great one much
like farve a lot of similarities to
farve but all the more reason that it
would be a compelling biopic
you know when mike he probably won the
biggest game the most significant game
uh you know and i i know everybody
refers to the 1958 championship game uh
colts giants is the greatest game ever
but and it and it well maybe
but
this game honestly
this game that where he won the super
bowl he predicted it beforehand the
colossal upset of the baltimore colts
uh it changed so much about pro football
and probably the biggest single victory
the most significant single victory it
showed that the afl could be on equal
footing with the nfl
uh and so i think that is a
i i love that pick i love that pick now
mike i would i'm going to pick a third
person here but i'm also going to say
that i i mean i think one of the things
about biopics
that could be really really fun is to
take guys who are totally unknown like
tim rosavich of the philadelphia eagles
i'm not going to pick him but tim
rosevich used to prove his toughness by
eating glass
and he's a total absolute nut job
and and he was i don't know if that's
more interesting on the front end or the
back end
well i'm sorry i i figured you might you
might you might say something like that
but but i would i would say for my for
my last draft choice here i will take
jack lambert
and i'll take jack lambert you know the
pittsburgh steelers linebacker because
jack lambert was discovered as a
219-pound linebacker at kent state
university when the steeler scout who
was there scouted him and they were
because of a heavy rain
that day they were practicing a walk
through in their parking lot and jack
lambert was going full speed and
tackling people on the hard top of a
parking lot
and then how great a player he was and
then post career he disappeared into the
forest
of pennsylvania to be a state game
warden
and so i just think he's got so much
interesting about his life and it was so
private i think that would be a totally
fascinating biopic to have somebody open
up the life and times of jack lambert
and you know that's a good one because
there's so much about him
that that we just don't know and we
never did know and the one thing that
that resonates for me from growing up
watching super bowl 10 when when cliff
harris came over to pat uh
who was the kicker roy girello on royal
missed the field goal roy giroud and and
jack lambert grabs cliff harris and
throws him to the ground i mean that was
just one of those moments where it gets
seared into your brain that he did that
but that was jack lambert and a guy who
was undersized by today's standards but
he got it done and he was a very
enigmatic character and you know you
mentioned jack lambert and i started
thinking about all those steelers
players and stats
you've suggested rocky blyer in this
little documentary show they did do yeah
a movie about rocky blair was a
made-for-tv movie about rocky blair
because he uh he fought in vietnam and
then came and and was a key component in
that steelers great team of the 70s i'm
going to go
kind of off the board here i'm going to
take a liberty with the rule um
i want to just do one on the 85 bears
and this is in keeping with the same
farv nameth just craziness and could you
imagine and it would be it would be
difficult you'd have to maybe focus on
four or five guys jim mcmahon and you
know richard dent and and but but it
would be
built around how this team all came
together that's right the fridge walter
payton how they all came together how
they all found themselves in the same
place at the same time how they managed
to to capture the the uh the fascination
of the entire country back in 1985 and
then after that they never did anything
they fell apart they should have won two
or three or four super bowls but i think
there's a hell of a story there to be
told and the right way to do it would be
to do it on the big screen
you know mike i i would there's so many
good ones that you could do but i think
some of them have been done for instance
the 30 for 30 on dion sanders was very
very good that was just done
but dion sanders is a totally
fascinating character because he
invented his persona when he looked at
the salary numbers of guys in the nfl he
invented prime time because he saw that
cornerbacks weren't getting paid so i'm
gonna i'm going to invent a cartoon
character and that's exactly what he did
and you know what it worked
and
bo jackson the same thing
those two guys in modern sports playing
two sports at one time
is absolutely unbelievable and
especially like dion sanders did
being the best cornerback in football
and starting in the world series i mean
that that is something that i think if
you think about it today you mentioned
before earlier in the show
about jameis winston you know when i
mentioned to jason light that year
that uh that jameis winston still was
thinking about playing baseball jason
light called his agents and said listen
this is a non-starter
if we can't have a clause in his
contract that prohibits him from playing
baseball while he's our quarterback
we're we're going to go elsewhere i
honestly think they would have taken
marcus mariota
but and so
it won't happen today or it probably
won't happen today
but there's something about kyler murray
and mike i've raised this as a specter
how about if john gruden who really
likes kyler murray
and who has so much draft choice
ammunition
in the next two years
how about if he got kyler murray with
the fourth pick in this draft
traded away derrick carter jacksonville
or miami or washington traded away derek
carr
and then
kyler murray is playing on the oakland
coliseum turf as a baseball player and a
football player
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports